bonjour ebf new surf 42
today's video is sponsored by babel the
number one language learning app
in the world with more than 10 million
subscriptions worldwide
it's often said that the life of a woman
in the middle ages was pretty tough
thanks to a distinct lack of job
opportunities
the unavoidable perils of childbirth and
a general commitment on the path of men
towards being in charge of everything
and that's all true but it's easy to
forget
life wasn't exactly a picnic for men
either
sure they got to have jobs and go
hunting and all that sort of thing
but they also faced a lot of pressure
and when i say pressure i'm not talking
about your regular run-of-the-mill
roof over the head and food on the table
kind of thing no
i'm talking about pressure of a rather
more
sensitive variety you see in the middle
ages
if a woman felt her husband wasn't
upholding
his end of the bedroom-based bargain in
their relationship
he was in for a world of trouble now
sure when faced with her husband's
malfunctioning manhood
a medieval mistress might simply have
patted him reassuringly on the back
and told him not to worry and that this
kind of thing happens to
everyone she might have even headed over
to the local witch or healer
and as for the medieval equivalent of
viagra
she might have done those things or
she might have skipped the foreplay and
taken her
erectionally challenged husband straight
to courts
because in the middle ages impotence
was a serious matter and one of the very
few reasons
for which a woman might divorce her
husband
but to do that she would have to take
her case to court
where her man's member would be
discussed
at length or not as the case may turn
out to be
as crazy as all that may sound impotence
annulment trials really did take place
in the middle ages
and some records of the proceedings
survive to this day
i love travelling and the french
countryside
is always my go-to however i often feel
rude
and sometimes embarrassed by my total
inability
to understand the language of the locals
so i'm using babel to learn to speak
french
from my experience language learning
apps don't get
any better than babel unlike other apps
that use
algorithms to generate lessons babel
lessons are created by
real people who have vast experience
with teaching languages
and you know what the results speak for
themselves
university studies have shown that just
15 hours of babble
is equal to a semester of college
spanish
and that doesn't surprise me because
after just a few days using
babble i've learned and can recall a
long list of friends phrases
that are actually really useful in
conversation
this is because babel prepares you for
situations you will actually encounter
in real life
the best thing about babble is that the
lessons are actually engaging
and fun and they've recently added some
brand new features
that i love such as language learning
games
short stories podcasts and culture clips
this keeps babble lessons exciting and
varied
unlike other learning methods that just
repeat phrases at you and send you to
sleep
what language have you always wanted to
learn
well you should start today by heading
to my link
below to get up to 50 off a babble
subscription
plus your first lesson absolutely free
for a limited time only don't miss it
guys
okay so what actually happened at a
medieval impotence trial
well for starters let's just say that if
you thought people in the middle ages
were all
rather coy you'd be wrong very wrong
if a woman decided to take her allegedly
impotent husband to
court the couple would be expected to
provide
evidence to support their case as you
might expect the two sides of the story
were often told very differently
so in order to get to the bottom of the
matter
an impotent investigation would take
place
with the man being subject to a public
and rather
detailed analysis of the contents of his
breaches
to facilitate this investigation
witnesses would be sought
to establish exactly what had been going
on in the couple's bedroom
well i've called them witnesses their
role was probably more akin to that of a
detective
the witnesses might have been medical
experts called upon to examine the man
or they might simply have been local
people connected to the defendant and
the plaintiff
who were simply called in to provide an
independent view
records of one such investigation
carried out between 1433
and 1434 yes it really did take that
long
provides some interesting insight into
the world of
medieval impotence trials catherine
barley filed for annulment of her
marriage to william barton
claiming he was impotent but then no
fewer than 13 men came forward to
testify
as to william's virility which if you
ask me
puts even more suspicion on the marriage
one man who made a point of telling the
court
he'd fathered 10 children and was
therefore something of an expert on the
subject
of erections claimed he had personally
seen william barton's penis and could
confirm
with some confidence that at time of
seeing and touching the alpha said rod
williams was longer and larger
than his own other witnesses also
compared williams
rod to theirs and several were quite
effusive in their brains
one claimed it was two handfuls long
and another that william had large unfit
testicles and other signs of virility
again considering the intimate knowledge
so many men seem to have
regarding her husband's penis you should
probably think catherine bali
had rather bigger concerns than her
husband's impotence
several women were called in to examine
williams wang
but apparently they were unable to reach
a unanimous conclusion as to its
usability
some were just as complementary as the
men had been
whilst others were much less so one
female witness
even told the court williams rod has no
value
which might just be the most damning
penis insult i've ever heard
not that i've heard too many
unfortunately we don't know the outcome
of this trial
as the rest of the court records have
been lost to history
so we only have the witness statements
but given the balance of testimonies in
this one it seems
likely the court would have ruled for
william rather than his
wife perhaps her allegation was
malicious
or maybe everything she said was true
and the many witnesses who testified for
william
and his evidently impressive penis
were protecting a friend from the shame
of being publicly judged impotent
we'll never know for sure sadly other
men
were not as lucky as william in the case
of tedia
lamherd and john sanderson the court
asked
three women to examine john and report
on their findings
whoever made the first such report
clearly wasn't overly worried about
hurting poor old john's feelings
because she really didn't hold back in
her assessment of the
gift god had given him describing john's
penis as
an empty intestine of muscled skin that
does not have any flesh in it
keen to give john's member every chance
of proving its innocence
another examiner even went so far as to
give it a little stroke
but unfortunately her ministrations
failed to have the desired effect as
well as testifying to john's
lack of virility witnesses fortedia also
claimed
both john and tedia had admitted they
hadn't been able to have sex
at all during their three-year marriage
despite much trying there were also
tellingly no children despite tedia
being a young woman of just 26
unlike the previous case we do know the
outcome of this one
and perhaps unsurprisingly the court
found in favour of tedia
and against the empty intestine of
muttled skin between
john's legs an annulment was duly
granted
both the cases we've looked at so far
were tried in england
but in france impotence investigations
could be even more detailed not to
mention
humiliating a french man accused of
impotence would be examined by a team of
priests
doctors and midwives who would expect
him to
prove the potency of his penis by
summoning up
his best direction for all to see even
going so far as to require
proof of ejaculation and if
anything on god's green earth is likely
to prevent a man from reaching
orgasm it's gathering a large group of
people around
to watch him try unsurprisingly
many of these men were unable to perform
under such circumstances
and when they couldn't they were given
two choices
they could accept the findings of the
examination
or they could demand a trial by congress
this involved husband and wife agreeing
to meet for some
attempted sex as a neutral location
in front of an even larger crowd of
excited onlookers
it was a bit like the fa cup final only
with sex instead of football amongst a
crowd would be the same team of priests
doctors and midwives
as had been present the first time
around all of whom
apart from the midwives would position
themselves behind a screen for the
duration
of the attempt emerging
only to examine the state of the
bedsheets when the deed was done
lovely it's clear that a lot of time and
effort used to go into
establishing the guilt or innocence of a
man accused of impotence
but what exactly does that tell us about
medieval society
first it's worth acknowledging that
impotence trials were generally an
indulgence of the wealthy
the cost to the couple of such a legal
undertaking
has been estimated at several thousand
pounds in today's money
so it's not something peasants would
have been concerning themselves with
it seems important trials were a bit
like soap operas for the upper classes
whose sex lives were probably avidly
dissected in local knitting circles
and backstreet taverns you might be
thinking all this graphic talk of sex
and
genitals is a bit surprising in a
society where the catholic church still
ran
pretty much everything but in reality
it's because of the church's influence
that these impotence investigations
took place to begin with the church
considered it
every married couple's religious duty to
have
sex in order to fulfill their sacred
vows an unconsummated marriage was just
as good as slapping god in the face
and once consummated you were expected
to
keep on pleasing god and ideally
create some children whilst you're at it
so
whilst today we would consider impotence
a private
marital matter throughout much of
history people would have considered
sex and marriage at least partly
a public matter marriage was
a public act of faith after all
the church really was all important to
medieval people
and for the most part the church and the
state
were one and the same it was therefore
quite natural
even inevitable that people's private
and family lives
were governed by the church the
existence of god
was unquestionable as was the importance
of fulfilling your duty to the church
to say the medieval church was
all-powerful
isn't quite accurate it was everything
to everyone medieval marriages were
orchestrated entirely by the church
much more so than his comment today the
church
therefore felt perfectly entitled to
make sure
a married man was doing his duty an
impotent man was considered a failure
and
if he were thought to have married
knowing full well he was impotent
beforehand
he would also be considered a deceiver
and a fraud
such a man would have married under
false pretenses
after all and would therefore have lied
to
god as well as his wife given
the significance of such an act it's not
surprising the medieval court went to
such
lengths to prove or disprove a man's
impotence
it really mattered and not just to the
frustrated wives
but the existence of the impetus trials
does not simply demonstrate the
dedication of medieval people to the
church and the importance they placed on
marriage and children
the fact that people were willing and
indeed
legally required to examine each other's
genitals in public
talk about them in quite graphic terms
and even have sex or attempt to with an
audience of strangers watching gone
is quite contrary to common 21st century
perceptions
of medieval people and their attitudes
we often think of medieval people as
being quite sexually repressed
and in some ways they were but for the
most part
they shared a fairly pragmatic view
towards sex
and were prepared to discuss it much
more frankly than many people are today
in what is truly a far more sexually
liberated period in history
these days impotence trials are well and
truly
a thing of the past but believe it or
not
impotence is still considered legal
grounds for divorce
in several u.s states so perhaps we
shouldn't laugh too hard at our medieval
ancestors
after all thanks for watching